happy Halloween sixty symbols viewers
okay so Halloween is upon us and diving
casting around looking for something
suitably astronomical that's celebrates
Halloween so our stretch today is to
talk about the witch's broom nebula
because some people think it does
resemble a witch's broom perhaps out of
Harry Potter I don't quite see it so
much but I other people do well in this
case we're looking at a supernova
remnant so this is the expanding shock
wave from a star that probably exploded
or 5,000 or 8,000 years ago and when a
star explodes it sort of throws its gas
out into space and that gas then
interacts with the interstellar medium
that's already out there
and heats it up and makes it glow and so
you have this big almost spherical ball
Fierce or hollow sphere of material
that's glowing that's how far the
explosions got and one of the sections
of this you think about a sphere the
bits that you're seeing a John you'd be
looking right through my hand right the
bit you're seeing face on you just be
seeing through my hand whereas here
you'd be seeing the full width of my
hand
so actually you see the ag's much more
clearly because you're looking through
more stuff and the witch's broom is one
small part of a much larger nebula
called the veil nebula which is actually
quite large it's about three degrees
across and to put that in perspective
your thumb outstretched covers an angle
of about two degrees on the sky so it's
slightly larger than your outstretched
thumb and when you think about it the
full moon itself is only half a degree
so this is actually quite a large object
on the sky it's really like a bubble
it's like a big bubble you're looking at
it's not a perfectly spherical bubble
because different bits have expanded by
slightly different amounts but basically
it's a big big hollow sphere you're
looking at you're talking about anything
which is expanding at sort of a thousand
kilometers per second or thereabouts oh
it's cracking along a fair old speed and
that's the reason why it glows at all is
because you've got this material that's
expanding outwards and basically
smacking into the material that's there
and shock heating it so it's only
because there are these very high speeds
involved that the thing gets hot enough
to glow in the dark it is quite bright
but that brightness is spread out over
this very large area which means it's
surface brightness is actually quite low
so it's very difficult to see and in
fact what you are seeing if you look
closely
the pictures you're seeing these sort of
filamentary rope-like structures the
shockwave has hit this diffuse gas and
although it's happening in a
three-dimensional shell you're really
only seeing it when when you look down
enough of it that it becomes visible and
that only happens on the edge when
you're looking down a fair amount of
material along the line of sight
it's just child so if you look at enough
places in the sky you'll start picking
out shapes and this one just happens to
end up looking like a broomstick if I
was in a spacecraft like the Space
Shuttle and I flew into the shockwave I
flew into this thing head-on which looks
like this big beautiful gentle thing any
any ideas what to expect when I go
through it like flying through a cloud
or would it be good night Irene it's a
good question
as one of those tricky ones that you'd
have to do a lot of calculations to
figure out in detail my guess would be
you probably wouldn't notice because the
densities are pretty low I mean it's
still pretty much the vacuum of space
it's only the only reason you see it is
because you know it's spread out over a
huge area and over that huge area
there's an awful lot of atoms so there's
another one called the witch head nebula
which is in some ways it's the same kind
of thing it's another of these clouds
out there in space which looks
remarkably like a witch's head I think
this is one of those cases where the
human eye is really good at picking out
faces even where there isn't anything to
see like that famous face on the moon
and those kinds of things and so this is
a this is that kind of feature that
there's a face like object in a cloud
and really what you've got there is a
thing called a reflection nebula you've
got a relatively bright star Rigel
nearby and then there's just this cloud
of gas next to it and the light from
Rigel is lighting up the cloud and then
some of that light is is just being
absorbed by the cloud and then
re-emitted in our direction sorry if
that's a rather bluish sort of tinge to
it which also adds to its vaguely witchy
spooky nature but the reason for that it
comes out the shade of blue is an sort
of interesting piece of physics which is
that the Rigel the star that's lighting
it up of course is emitting light from
all across the spectrum red light green
light blue light but the red light tends
to go straight through it's only the
blue light they get scattered towards us
and in fact it's the same kind of
physics as why the sky looks blue when
you look at the sky because of course
when you're looking at the sky you're
seeing scattered sunlight and sunlight
gets more scattered by the molecules in
the atmosphere at the blue end of the
spectrum than the red
the spectrum and here it's the same kind
of physics but here what's doing the the
scattering is actually dust grains
little dust grains but they have the
same property that they tend much more
to scatter blue light than red light red
light go straight through the blue light
gets scattered towards us
the Halloween itself is actually an
astronomical date it's known as a cross
quartered date in the calendar so it's
halfway between the equinox and the
winter solstice so the equinox being
where there's equal amounts of day and
night the solstice being the longest
night of the year and so this is halfway
in between and traditionally it kind of
marks the beginning the real beginning
of winter